angela is in ohio hi Angela your
question for dr. John and me hi thank
you so much for taking my call I am a
huge fan of everything Dave Ramsey oh my
god I'm super nervous we've never lost a
patient clear okay good um so I'm
calling because about three and a half
weeks ago my husband confessed to me
that he has a prescription drug
addiction I had no idea I was completely
blindsided so that very day we found a
rehab facility he's been there since
he's coming home next week but in the
meantime I found out he had sent we had
an emergency fund that saved of $30,000
he cleaned it out he took as much liquid
as he could get and he put himself into
credit debt of about $70,000 and I'm
aware of just via cash advances so at
this point I'm just trying to figure out
and he's going to clean up his own mess
of course but I'm trying to be
supportive do we go with chapter 13
bankruptcy do we consolidate do we pay
things off some of its in collections
there's about 10 credit cards I found
some of it's just four to six months
late so it's kind of a mess right now so
I'm just looking for some guidance
tough month Mary yeah you're going to be
like the rest of us 2020 you don't want
to see it again
yep exactly so are you working outside
the home I am I'm in education what do
you make 71 thousand what does he make
he makes ninety five so $160,000 income
to clean up $70,000 worth of debt
correct so that's really not a problem
correct it doesn't sound like one I
guess because it's going to collections
and it's past due and I don't have any
liquid I'm clean it there's nothing
there narrative collectors you know what
do you what do you do about that they're
not gonna do anything by the time you
can pay them back mm-hmm so I mean if
you start paying you know you start
talking about Palicki this has gone in
12 months what you should be fairly easy
right
the biggest problem is you're just
trying to you're you you got knocked on
your back I mean so your whole world
changed and so you're trying to get your
head around if you had been gradually
kind of knew this was there and but you
didn't know we had a problem and you
didn't know you had a financial problem
and those are all new things right I
thought we had a fully funded emergency
fund I thought we were on baby step six
and I had no idea and I and I am in
charge of the money you know and I he
just but you know the addiction makes
you sneaky Oh makes you lie and
manipulate then defeat to get deceitful
exactly all that extra liars do you have
somebody in your life that you can sit
with that will walk alongside you or a
group that's gonna walk alongside you
because you're gonna have to do a couple
of things you can have to mourn the that
I learned this phrase when I joined this
team you're gonna have to mourn the
financial infidelity you're gonna have
to mourn the stability that you knew in
the long cut loss of trust there right
as your husband has to rebuild that and
you're gonna have to walk alongside your
husband and this this journey together
but you're also gonna have to learn to
reach rust you because you trusted him
yeah you trusted your sense of
understanding what's going on in your
home you know this sense of money and
what I often feel here people experience
as they walk through this is they
understand they gotta learn how to read
trust their husband they got to learn to
read climp the the financial mess gotta
do they forget to learn to retrace
themselves and that's ends up being the
most painful violation mmm-hmm do you
have people that you can walk with I
have a lot yeah I have an amazing group
of friends as my choice and family I
mean I am so blessed to have everybody
in my life they have come forward and
helped me in ways I could never have
imagined so yes I have a lot of helpers
thank God for that
so you had $100,000 change in position
from 30 plus 70 - yes and yeah your guy
that you thought was solid isn't right
and so there's a lot to be sad about
very much naughty and mad about and not
to be stay sad or stay mad but but I
mean if those are just real emotions I
just want to say y'all allow those are
normal human beings have emotions like
that in this kind of crap and if you
don't feel it and if you shove them down
and try to get the problem solving
what's what's that debut they have a
high rate of resurrection or in
counseling we call them leakage they
will find a way out you can deal with or
they will make their way out all over
your marriage as strong as they come and
ups and downs and it's overall I would
say it's just confusing I'm just
confused
it is disorienting what you can do is
you can lay out some very clear
principles with his coaches and
counselors that say you know you have to
re trust by being worthy of trust
trustworthy not not falling off the
wagon again not lying not manipulating
not doing drugs and so we're gonna have
a real clear understanding what winning
looks like there and then we're gonna
have a real careful mathematical formula
that says we're gonna be on a budget and
we're gonna take seventy thousand
dollars in debt making a hundred and
sixty thousand dollars and so we're
going to clean that up you know
this is a seven thousand dollars a month
yeah
and when you just make your list of
smallest to largest plus or minus a
barking dog that you want to get rid of
you know on the list right but you know
you just start knocking it out seven
thousand dollars they're not gonna bark
much and you don't think bankruptcy is
the way to go no you're not bankrupt
you're not bankrupt make 160 need to pay
70 and you need a little perspective
from you so thank you you're not even
close to back you know you're scared
you're mad you're confused and you're
and you're pissed off and all of those
things are right but you're not bankrupt
in six months from now you're gonna be
super pissed off because you're gonna
have want this to be over and he's gonna
have been working his steps and he's
gonna be going to his group and he is
going to have rededicated himself to his
marriage in you and you are still gonna
have the broom and the dustpan
in this crap nothing wrong it's gonna
suck and that's why you've got that's
what we say the good news is your life
if he stays clean and does his steps for
the next year and you work the you know
your Dave Ramsey system and you bust
through this debt in one year 12 months
from today you're gonna have your life
back I pray I pray that's exactly what
happens well somewhat unto Him well it's
somewhat up to him I mean he's got a
he's got a heal he's got to keep walking
the healing but you can if you can keep
the emotions dialed and know that
they're there but also stay on a path
mathematically this is very doable in 12
months mathematically okay I feel better
thank you I just I had a feeling that's
what you were gonna say but I just feel
like I needed to call and hear you say
it yourself yeah if you told me you make
25 thousand dollars a year you might be
bankrupt yeah right but you're not right
so the bad news is you got a hold the
good news is you got really nice big
trouble yeah and we can do it yeah you
can definitely well I'm very hopeful I
really am what are you guys in Ramsey
plus I know okay I'm gonna pay for it
well that Ramsey plus is all of the
stuff together it's every dollar
it's Financial Peace University it's all
the tools under one heading and I'm
gonna give you a one-year membership to
walk with you guys while you're walking
your year out okay thank you so much now
jump in use the every dollar budget let
him walk with you on the every dollar
budget he needs to participate and carry
the emotional weight of these financial
decisions you don't need to be his mommy
for the next 12 months financially
yep that's hard cuz I'm the leader I am
the control freak yeah but he that'll
help you trust him and it'll help him he
could demonstrate it real time yeah it's
it's his payback
he carries emotionally and financially
carries the weight of this because it's
his mass it's a way he can bring
restoration back yeah that's what I'm
looking for it's exactly right